tom brady lying or telling the truth
well he's a very good friend of mine
he's telling the truth and so is the
coach telling the truth all right
well first of all i'm
not ever been a professional quarterback
but jack kemp was a very close friend
for 10 years how do you go out on the
field as a quarterback
and not notice that the ball is deflated
i'm not saying any of a brady person i'm
just saying
explain to me as a professional
quarterback
how you could have picked the ball up
the first time right
now
you know in this kind of weather this
wall shouldn't feel like this right
tom brady telling the truth or not
you know i'm thankful i don't have to
weigh in on that issue but it does make
it a little easier to support seattle
what's your gut saying well i don't know
i i don't know and and and i frankly
haven't followed it uh that close and
now
uh i mean everybody has an opinion on
that and you you and i played played
some football played some catch uh i was
state game and i just want to tell you
right now those footballs heavily
underflated
just so you know